so fans have noted much less sex scenes
in season two compared to season one
here's the thing the sex scene that does
exist
i was like hey
hi
all right spoiler alert well first of
all before spoiler alert i look like
straight up out of the 80s because we're
doing an 80s episode and although i kind
of like my hair and my makeup so i would
do this now so i don't know why i'm
apologizing but spoiler earlier people
i'm about to dish all my opinions on
bridgeton season two that's right if you
have not watched it yet that's your
problem
you should probably tune out now
because i'm about to talk about all of
it but for everyone else that has you
know you are caught up please pull up a
chair put the kettle on because i'm
about to talk all the tea on bridget's
in season two and i loved it and i
watched it all in one day night day
slash night i couldn't stop
it's good
[Music]
i love this show so much
i'm very in it just shout out to andy he
made that look at this this is amazing
it looks like it it looks like lady
whistle down society papers come on
dearest gentle reader
this is my julie anderson
i'm like meryl streep with accents
did you miss me
okay so bridgeton season two is out now
on netflix and it was a delicious season
we love it we love it i'm so excited
about it oh there is just so much
greatness though with this i'm gonna be
honest with you i didn't think
that i could like season two like even
as much as season one because season one
was so good but i kind of liked season
two even better
like it was
it was so good and i didn't see it
coming i was like
anthony why are we doing a whole season
on anthony and i was kind of like
and then
i
could not stop watching it cut to i'm
like the president of his fan club
i love anthony anyway
anthony oh sorry anthony i'm not classy
so it's just like
anthony
oh my god i'm not good at synopsis in 60
seconds i can't do anything i bridgeton
is so good okay so there's like you know
there's that character like anthony the
brother and he comes in and and you
think oh my god he's got to get it he's
got to get he's the by count he's got to
get him on contest and so anyway he's
like who which girl will be in the
season and then like all of a sudden
there's the newbie the sharmas that come
back into town and it's just amazing
because the older sister like catches
him like talking like guy talk and so
she totally knows who he is like deep
down and she gives him so much
the whole show it's amazing and she's so
smart and she's so different from the
last like daphne the last character
because she's like more of like a bold
like older sister she's looking out you
kind of like what's the backstory there
and there's no backstory and anyway i
don't like porsche i don't like that
character i don't i'm like there's this
whole other thing that i'm just like oh
you know what karma but anyway it's
really good even how she handles that at
the end it's you know what it is is it's
tension who doesn't love tension i
thrive off tension it's just a nice
thing
nothing even has to happen just the
tension
[Music]
hey you're gonna love it
[Music]
thoughts on anthony is the new mel lead
like you know the first season
i liked anthony in the first one but
like kind of was just kind of like
people people like you know i could have
picked him out of a lineup but it wasn't
my favorite character obviously because
i was focused on do casings and then
season two happens which i think this is
brilliant how they're doing all these
different perspectives and stories from
different characters
i am in love with anthony anthony
whatever i almost like literally i love
their attention
more so than i loved duke hastings and
japanese i'm just saying
uh thoughts on the new female leads i
love kate i think that she is so i think
i mean edwina is awesome she's kind of
got to be that sister because in order
for kate to be able to be the other role
and have you know what she's doing in
that relationship and with the writers
i'm sure they had to have you know the
different kind of perspectives but she's
more the sweet one and has kind of been
taking care of her whole life and
i don't really ever like she does a
beautiful job acting i just mean i don't
relate at all that i like the one that
has to kind of struggle and i like that
kind of you know heroin in the in the
show so um kate is great she's smart
she's bold she's funny
very sarcastic and she
loves some tension
attention is the word of the day
so thoughts on the scandalous love
triangle in season two
is there a triangle
i mean i know that edwina's there but
she's kind of like that person
that like you're on and you know out
with friends and it's like happens to be
three of you but really you're just like
this person's just here because it's
really about the two and it's yeah
because she's great like i said and
possibly has a prince in her future or
whatever because at the end if you saw
that and if you didn't sorry
but um i like edwina and i do like that
they didn't pass edwina off for like
just some kind of
you know
floaty girl like she still at the end
like found her boldness and like
you know held everybody kind of the fire
for their actions and stuff like that i
did i did like her in the end her
character kind of grew on me um she kind
of became more of like a woman instead
of a girl i feel like um it's not really
a triangle though it's just a a to b
line is what it is and it is directly
from anthony to kate and it is awesome
and the in between is tension
[Music]
is this not the hottest line in the
entire season
anthony bridgeton
you are the bane of my existence and the
object of all my desires
this this that scene
when kate came chasing after anthony and
they went in that room and he got real
close it was in her ear and i was like
oh my god
and she and i was like hey
hi
it was i was like what is hap
if you like tension
it's so good
it's so good
so fans have noted much less sex scenes
in season two compared to season one
here's the thing you don't miss that and
first of all the sex scene that does
exist
and then you're provided with like more
details because whenever she has her
like
memory of it
i'm like i literally rewound i was like
i'll remember that word i was like and i
rewound and i was like that wasn't in
the initial out in the gardens moment
and then i was like you gave us more you
gave us like memories of why didn't you
show us the whole thing anyway so it was
just it's a good it's worth it that
because you know why it's not about just
like
some of the mystery is nice the tension
is nice you know then it's done
and you've done it and it's like you
know there's never like the brush of oh
what might happen you know and here's
the thing i like about this seat that
was different from last season
it was a little more of like like i love
jane austen kind of stuff so i'm like
it was a little more of like just
tension like there wasn't as much well
that library scene with the ladder in
the first one hey
i love that one um but there wasn't
really as much if there was stuff like
that
yes
but it's more of like a lot of like oh
brush by glance here
oh it's wrong but it's right
so nice
anyway so you're gonna love this season
[Music]
i love how they do the music too because
i remember the first news i was
listening and i was like it's like
ariana grande or something i was like
listening and i was like wait what
because i could tell like what it was
like the melody and i love that they do
that they take modern music and they
they just put an orchestra to it like a
string with quartet and it's like so
cool and so beautiful oh i love that
they use dancing on my own i thought
that was really cool
um robin i thought that was cool they
did you ought to know they did atlantis
which i was like you just brought alanis
morissette into richardson how does this
get better
the tension
um how many sips of tea would i give
bridget in season two out of five i'd
give it if we're gonna look i'm gonna
pour this is cute
you're fancy um i
i
know i know i'm about to go to a show
but look i was also a waitress so i feel
like i've got it how many sips of tea
out of five for bridges in season two
not five seven monica level seven from
friends like seven lumps of sugar
seven spots of tea
seven
just
yes
let me know in the comments your
favorite part of season two and
subscribe to my scrumptious channel um i
bid you farewell
it's you're welcome
[Music]
you